In order to improve this function I have to ask myself, "What do each of the loops do?"
"And can I implement that in another way other than with nested loops?"
The answer seems to be that each of the nested loops is incrementing the word by one letter,
from abcd to abcde, and then it's checking to see if we have a new word,
and it's checking to see if we should stop
if what we have so far is not a prefix of any word in the dictionary.
If I don't want to have nested loops what I want instead is a recursive procedure.
I'm going to have the same structure as before.
I'm going to start off by initializing the results to be the empty set,
and then I'm going to have some loops that add elements to that set,
and then I'm going to return the results that I have built up.
Then I'm going to start the loops in motion by making a call to this recursive routine.
What I want you to do is fill in the code here.